si en ce moment avec le nombre important
de personnes infectées par le virus les
nouvelles sont loin d'être agréable on
peut tout de même se réjouir de quelques
informations comme ces nouvelles du
joueur blaise matuidi a pas par le cos
vide 19 qui vient d'être guéri c'est sur
son site internet que le club de la
juventus de turin a indiqué que deux des
ses joueurs qui avaient été contaminées
par le virus sont aujourd'hui de nouveau
sur pied une nouvelle rassurante car les
stars sont nombreuses à avoir été
atteintes par ce virus souvent en
compagnie de nombreuses personnes a
serré des mains ou à voyager les
célébrités ne sont pas épargnés par le
cos vides il y a quelques jours c'est le
chroniqueur sportif pierre ménès qui
expliquait sur les réseaux être touchés
par le virus même chose pour patrick
bruel qui expliquait avoir été
diagnostiqué positif
même chose pour le chanteur christophe
qui fin mars a été hospitalisée en
urgence pic michel boujenah le prince
charles julien lepers le rappeur mhd ont
tous également traverser cette épreuve
malheureusement certains comme pape
diouf ou manu dibango n'ont pas survécu
à l'infection
[Musique]
ouais c'est vrai que j'aime bien mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
dînent laval avoir eu comme une dizaine
est ce que vous aimez les gens qui
déclare veulent avoir le comider neuf
fois ce que vous trouvez que c'est moi
je trouve ça bien moi michel boujenah le
début il n'était pas bien il l'a dit
parce qu'il ya des gens qui disent ouais
il faut pas le dire faut le garder pour
soi qui est souvent pensé mathieu moi je
suis très important parce que justement
il faut arrêter de diviser la
transcender en disant voilà il ya les
gens qui sont riches dans les boas par
la maladie touche pas ils ont accès à
des soins et tout et ceux qui sont là
les mauvais quartiers qui sont malades
ben non pardon le virus qui touche tout
le monde on a vu le nombre de célébrités
qui ont été malades qui sont souvent
âgés tout ça j'ai une pensée pour
christophe le chanteur il faut savoir
qu'il est actuellement à chaud analyse
proches qui le connaît il est dans le
coma il est sous respirateur artificiel
on espère vraiment qu'il va s'en sortir
mais pour l'instant on est dans le coma
total look non c'est très important de
montrer justement les people bas que les
people sont en ce moment on est tous
tous tous pareil tu as saadiya pas de
risques a pas de pauvres
on est tous dans le même bateau je sais
bien qu'ils en parlent connais
maintenant vraiment ronnie ouais moi je
sais qui tu fais bien de parler ce sujet
parce que chez les réseaux sociaux comme
audi mathieu on est dans cette merde on
est tous ensemble et xavier il n'y a pas
de différence et de parents elle aurait
repris et j'ai horreur des réseaux
sociaux
il ya des sous merdes qui qui disent on
a besoin s'en fout c'est ainsi c'est
elle même parier
mach est assez parlant de ça et ça on
devrait l'interdire et elle et moi je
vais jouer avec team usa
le bloc est systématiquement c'est une
horreur les mecs qui part qu'il aime pas
la personne ne dit c'est bien fait pour
ta gueule j'ai vu j'ai lu des mots rim
et des mauvais tweet
quand pierre belet sa tasse de thé mais
il faut pas qu'elles ont déconné wac m'a
bien sûr mais tu as raison c'est des
conneries ça non mais c'est vrai
jean-michel les pme et les people qui
disent qu'ils ont commis 19 qui
communiquait ce que vous ça vous plaît
aux 845 choque pas surtout que ça fait
un peu d'informations positives serre
que quand on l'a l'issue peut être
heureuse témoignent qu'ils ont eue qui
s'en sortent bien parce que c'est vrai
que les nouvelles quand on regarde bfm
d'autres chaînes d'info c'est toujours
c'est toujours très anxiogène ce cd mort
des gens sur respirateur etc
on peut la voir et s'en sortir bien
heureusement et moines que voilà on peut
être on peut s'en sortir de ça c'est
bien alors moi je voudrais dire moi j'ai
une très très grosse pensée pour
christophe le chanteur à l'enjeu
l'adorent mathieu aussi je sais qui
jamais n'ont rien et voilà j'espère
vraiment vraiment qu'il va aller mieux
et voilà s'il va mieux franchement je
vais faire une grosse fête parce que
j'adore ce mec voilà je voulais le
garder